all right Jason
uh where'd you grow up where are you
from originally from Lake Illinois
where's that Crystal Lake Illinois
Crystal Lake
tell me about your family you uh you're
related to the Whitaker yes my dad's uh
the brother your dad's the brother of
their father yeah I see
you describe your childhood I assume
it's different than this one growing up
in Illinois
different lifestyle out there
um
moved to Crystal Lake High School
Central High School
uh
you graduate no I got my GED though yeah
would you guys come down and visit yeah
we came to visit every year come down
and visit and everything
what Memories do you have of visiting
Whitakers when you were a kid
uh
not really
visiting them but we come down we stop
and talk to them all the time
what were your thoughts on it because
certainly it's an unusual yeah it's
unusual but
they're like just like everybody else
yeah nice as can be yeah they'll get
their shirt off the back for you yeah
real friendly and everything
how old are you now I'm 44 44. yeah
and uh after school what kind of stuff
are you doing are you working I was
working in the factories doing uh making
drill bits putting several factory jobs
you got in trouble with the law yeah
quite a few times really yeah what kind
of stuff do you get in trouble for I
went to prison for aggravated battery
and MOB action when I was 17.
this is in Illinois in Illinois
how much time have you done uh all
together probably about 15 years 15
years different different defenses
different offenses yeah
do you have kids yeah I got three kids
three kids and where are they back in
Illinois no uh my two daughters are in
Wisconsin
Jessica and Julie I got four grandkids
by them
did you uh you just got you just got out
of jail recently right yeah
you um
where do you think you'll settle down
here in West Virginia or
probably not I'm thinking about going to
Wisconsin be closer to my kids
but what is your take on on the Whitaker
family I mean you you know them I love
them to death they're great people uh
they'll help anybody if they can yep
real friendly yeah this part of the
country is is interesting yeah because
you've got some of the most salt of the
earth people you'll ever meet mixed in
with
people are into drugs and yeah you know
a lot of crime and a lot of stuff going
on have drugs been a part of your life
yes they have
when did that start uh probably when I
was about 14 years old
and you uh
you you
continue with that or you know I've quit
the drugs I'm going going through a
suboxone clinic now oh you are so you
were using what heroin and Ice meth
crystal meth yeah which is really
popular out here yeah
it's you can find it easy around here
[Music]
a lot of trouble to be found here in
West Virginia yeah
you can you can find trouble what would
you look for did you get in trouble here
as well or just Illinois here too here
too
what's your biggest regret in your life
uh going to prison to
the second time
is for uh
sexual assault on a minor that was that
right yeah
at the time I didn't know she was on her
age I was 20 years old
and
at the time I was on doing drugs
everybody around me was doing drugs I
met a few friends that was
on drugs and everything she told you she
was how old she told me she was 18 but
guessed she wasn't she was told 14 14.
yeah
yeah that'll get you some prison time
right yeah and now you're a sex offender
yes because you have to deal with that
that's a drag
biggest mistake of my life yeah
what do you think of this part of the
country it seems like drugs are just
rampant here yeah
everybody's on them yeah
this family stays clear of him yeah yeah
they haven't even they've never don't
even drink alcohol
you ever consider living here
sometimes but sometimes not it's just
hard to find work around here it's
yeah that's the hard part here for
everybody
what's your biggest fear now
losing my family yeah
yeah friends
uh Associates
no one really gonna call friends right
and everybody I know was on drugs and
where I'm trying to stay clean it's
harder for me to stay clean with
everybody around me on is it harder for
you to stay clean out here in West
Virginia or in Illinois
it's harder to stay off of drugs here
harder to stay off because everybody's
usually using them yeah yeah I would
think so
what was your favorite memory from your
life
when my daughter was born my two girls
best part of my life was when they were
born
you talk to him still yeah I talked to
my oldest daughter Jessica still
my youngest daughter she
really doesn't have much to do with me
right
maybe you can fix that I'm hoping I can
yeah
stay away from the drugs is probably a
big part of that yeah yeah
sure they don't do drugs or nothing like
that they're good girls real good girls
so you remember growing up with with Ray
and Freddie and yeah Tammy Lorraine and
all of them yeah what was it like
whatever they like his kids Ray was a
very different person
15 20 years ago right yeah
he was always with uh Freddie I remember
him Freddie always together
yeah Freddie was very similar to what
Rey is now but Rey was a
wild Tasmanian Devil yeah he was
I remember
the first time I tried to photograph him
it was probably
2004 or something like that he uh
I asked him to sit stand with his with
Timmy and and Freddy for a photo and he
stood right in front of the lens two
inches away from the lens and I asked
him no if you could stand back with your
brothers and he just screamed his pants
wasn't falling around his ankles he went
to kick a metal garbage can with his
pants falling around he still does that
he just still does yeah he still throws
his bits yeah I haven't seen him lately
do that but I remember that and he would
do it over and over again I'm like I'll
never get this guy to stand for a photo
and eventually he did
but he's such a lovable dude you're
pretty or Ray Ray yeah well Freddie was
too yeah yeah they were ought to get
always together yeah they look the same
too yeah
what do you think is going on with his
family is it genetic is it
is it because the the parents were
because I guess the
is it the grandfathers that were twin
brothers I think so I'm not really for
sure about that
yes it's it's confusing but then you
know if somebody does the homework on
the genetics which there is a video on
YouTube talking about this
it gets very convoluted and because
there were twin brothers
that are both
grandparents I think of of this chain of
of Offspring I think it gets very
complicated
I just look at him as they're just
mental they're just mentally challenged
yeah yeah do you think it could be
environmental or do you think it's
something that they inherited from the
because they inherited probably they
inherited you think because they were
there were quite a few Offspring how
many are they 15 kids 14 kids 14 or 15
yeah yeah and a lot of them had the same
alert similar problem
you would think somewhere along the line
they'd catch on and say hey maybe we
shouldn't have so many kids yeah
probably been the best bet yeah
what do you what do you see for your
future what would you like to be doing
if I'd like to give me a job and place
my own
just
live life to its fullest yeah but like
make of it
yeah you're still young yeah
what emotions you go through now are you
angry about what happened to you are you
depressed or what kind of stuff you go
through
angry at what I did thank you yourself
yeah yeah
yeah it's it's it's in prison thinking
about it I knew if I knew she was
underage I would have never messed with
her I wouldn't it's not the way I am
yeah but then drugs change your yeah
alter your mental state and make stuff
like that more likely right yeah
but you know I should have known better
if I would have known her age nothing
would have ever happened
and I regret that to this day because
today I ruined my my life is ruined
because of it
nobody understands you know did
just happened I wasn't preying on nobody
and Jason what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
I always ask the age
do you think prison
rehabilitates no I don't at all no
they just throw you in there and you're
on your own you do what you got to do
with a spot
yeah my life has a way of rehabilitating
it yeah you melt it with age and yeah
you should be crazy wild when I was
younger if I've calmed down
just trying to live life now to his
fullest give an example of what your
typical Behavior was when you were a 20
year old
20 years old I was
ready to fight anybody and everybody
you threatened to pull a gun on me once
yeah I remember that no I don't remember
that
yeah it's just protecting my family yeah
yeah I get it
I get it
it's just I didn't know who you was or
what your what Your meanings were for my
family so yeah I gotta do what I got to
do to protect them
no I'm I'm certainly I don't fit in here
I'm a city slicker coming into this
weird part of the country with all my
equipment it's like what the hell is
going on yeah it's part of the
neighborhood you don't just show up
unannounced no you don't
I do but yeah most people don't
all right Jason thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you I wish you
lots of luck now you're free all right
thank you all right thanks